okay let's get to audience questions
first audience questions today very
popular topic that we've received a
bunch of questions on this one is from
evgenia saying David do you own bitcoins
or other crypto currencies what do you
think about them and people who buy them
do you understand
Bitcoin Pat no I I don't I don't really
understand it either I actually own some
Bitcoin but I have really no idea how it
works and I've I get all these explainer
sent to me every time I mention it like
hey here's a really simple guide to how
Bitcoin actually works and I still don't
really get it but at least conceptually
I can talk about a few elements of it so
number one yes I do own some Bitcoin
aetherium and litecoin
I've been doing what's called dollar
cost averaging in which means buying
little amounts of it over a long period
of time for about the last nine months
so I've accumulated a little bit of
Bitcoin etherium and litecoin which is
sort of the three I believe anyway the
three biggest crypto currencies right
now what do I think about them my
involvement in Kryptos is completely
speculative and I have a friend who has
something like 5 or 10% of all his money
in crypto currency and he also agrees
it's totally speculative and in fact I'm
now reading there's this really really
good book on bubbles called irrational
exuberance by Robert Shiller and the
book is now in its third edition and I'm
reading that right now and in it he
talks about stock market bubbles and
real estate bubbles and I believe and he
has said in some interviews that
cryptocurrency could be a major major
bubble and there's this idea that's out
there that crypto currencies are really
going to become major currencies at some
point in the future and they're going to
be used in a significant way to
circumvent currency exchange and legal
regulations and to have anonymous money
transfers I'm open to that and I clearly
don't totally disbelieve that because I
am slowly buying Bitcoin litecoin and
aetherium but I do wonder if there is a
major major bubble happening there as
well and so my opinion of people who buy
cryptocurrency I don't have any sort of
generalized opinion like if someone says
to you
at that there in Bitcoin do you think
that person is particularly smart or
dumb or do you just not really have an
opinion depends of when they bought in I
guess because if you look over just the
past couple years the price of Bitcoin
is skyrocket it's not way up it's nearly
six thousand dollars they're arrested
now maybe I'd call that into question
but a few years ago good move listen the
same thing happened with the stock
market that's what the Bitcoin
enthusiasts will say they'll say you
know the stock market was just barely at
a thousand four years and at the time
there was really no idea that it was
going to go much further the idea was it
might go to a thousand but then come
back down or not and now the stock
market is at twenty three thousand of
course those aren't inflation-adjusted
numbers but nonetheless and maybe
bitcoin will eventually be worth twenty
thousand dollars a coin I don't know but
in any case I don't have any particular
opinion about people who buy Bitcoin
I've got a little bit of it I do worry
that there is a bubble building within
cryptocurrency but I don't know the
future of it and anyone who pretends to
I think sort of like predicting the
future of the economy I don't think
anybody really can can tell you with any
certainty what's going to happen